Дві жінки, які обрали нібито "чоловічі" професії
і досягли успіху!
Ліза Тіле, 26 років, пілоткиня.
Уже в 15 вона знала, що хоче літати.
Натхненням для Лізи став її брат, який теж працює пілотом.
Щоденні подорожі в екзотичні місця - лише частина її роботи.
В інший час пілотам доводиться постійно вчитися.
- У нас постійні навчальні перевірки на симуляторі,
а також навчальні рейси на справжньому літаку.
Тому потрібно щоразу готуватися й невпинно вчитися,
щоб весь час бути в курсі усього найактуальнішого
в нашій сфері.
Пілоткинь у всьому світі не так уже й багато:
з майже 180 тисяч пілотів у всьому світі
лише 5% - жінки. У німецьких авіакомпаніях - 6%.
Багатьом усе ще незвично бачити жінку в кабіні літака.
- Реакція пасажирів зазвичай дуже позитивна,
але є й ті, хто злегка здивований, коли
перед виходом із літака на місці пілота стоїть дівчина.
Вони по кілька разів обертаються, дивляться,
але всі вони приємно здивовані.
Упередження й гендерні кліше існують у багатьох професіях.
З цим зіткнулася і Сандра Геґеманн.
У 30 років вона отримала диплом зі спеціалізацією "Машинобудування",
а потім вирішила спробувати себе в ремеслі й стала теслею.
- Найпоширеніше упередження, мені здається, -
це те, що ми занадто слабкі, щоб тягати важкі речі.
У майстерні всі знають, на що ми здатні, а на що ні.
З клієнтами трапляється зовсім по-різному.
Одного разу 80-річна клієнтка кілька хвилин
виглядала за кут і питала, чи прийде ще чоловік.
А є й ті, хто цим захоплюється.
Нас уже не раз жінки розціловували, вони були
просто щасливі і зворушені тим, що ми це робимо
і що в нас усе так добре виходить.
Сандра - одна з тих небагатьох жінок, які зважилися
здобути професії, що традиційно вважалися чоловічими.
Як і пілоткинь, жінок, які займаються теслярством,
у Німеччині лише 6%.
І причина тут - не в обмеженнях, пов'язаних із навчанням.
Їх немає.
Багато компаній були б раді навчати більше дівчат,
якби вони самі приходили.
- Я б не сказала, що хтось із колег
мене інакше сприймає або що хтось до мене ставиться по-іншому.
Але в цій майстерні завжди були жінки.
Завжди було так, що тут навчали теслярству
як чоловіків, так і жінок. Думаю, що це просто стало
чимось абсолютно нормальним, ми вже звикли
до цього й нам не здається це чимось смішним.
- У цій професії дуже мало жінок, тому що
все ще живе стереотип, що це під силу
лише колегам-чоловікам. І просто нам занадто мало
розповідають про це у школах. У 2019-му
вже само собою зрозуміло, що жінки теж можуть бути пілотами.
Ліза і Сандра сподіваються, що з них братимуть приклад
дедалі більше дівчат, і не лише в Німеччині.